[Música]
en una era de escándalos guerras
culturales y fachadas muchos tienen
miedo de expresar sus opiniones
Así que reunimos a siete extraños
protegimos sus identidades y les hicimos
siete preguntas polémicas
que revelarán estos enmascarados
[Música]
si su respuesta es afirmativa enciendan
su luz que se pudra la policía
[Música]
hace que hay supuestos policías buenos
pero todos trabajan en una organización
llena de individuos que son en esencia y
en su mayoría racistas además la
historia de la policía es importante
empezaron como patrullas de esclavos y
rociaban perros para atraparlos eso es
lo que representa su placa no se trata
solo de un insignia ellos no nos
protegen a nosotros por eso no nos
sentimos a salvo que se pudran
estoy de acuerdo contigo en el primer
punto sé que hay algunos policías buenos
porque tengo un primo que es policía
pero sé que el resto de las personas que
forman parte de esa organización son
racistas e intentan seguir inculcando
esa forma de pensar que se pudran ahora
todo se unirán a la
no estoy de acuerdo con la frase porque
nunca he tenido una mala experiencia con
la policía jamás no es necesario vivir
una mala experiencia para darte cuenta
del daño que han hecho entiendes Porque
siendo el peso de mis ancestros en otras
situaciones de mi vida no en mis
encuentros con la policía no quiero
involucrar otros temas en este punto de
la discusión pero me parece interesante
que solo los hombres negros estuvimos de
acuerdo con la frase sí no estoy del
todo de acuerdo porque sé que existen
policías negros que en verdad quieren
protegernos y que viven por servir a
nuestra comunidad ni siquiera sé qué
sería de nosotros se acabáramos con el
sistema policial por completo yo
tendrías mucho miedo porque pienso que
esa no es la solución para el problema
que atravesamos y sé que los hombres
negros son quienes suelen pasar por
estas situaciones incómodas pero
que lo único que le importa a la gente
es la brutalidad policial cuando
realmente hay otros problemas creo que
el rechazo aumenta medida que tienes más
malas experiencias por eso en mi caso
todo empezó cuando era niño y te tenían
a mi padre lo interrogaban y lo acosaban
sin ningún motivo luego yo lo viví de
adulto en Texas cuando compré armas por
primera vez la registre y seguí todos
los pasos al pie de la letra pero me
siguen deteniendo y me revisan todo el
cuerpo como si hubiese hecho algo mal
ver como la pasaba mi padre y luego
vivir experiencias similares son el
motivo de mi rechazo
los asiáticos los tratan de forma
racista
[Música]
Tengo una vecina que tiene
muchos privilegios es asiática y se casó
con un hombre blanco siento que hoy en
día en Estados Unidos las mujeres
asiáticas están intentando ser las
nuevas mujeres blancas de la sociedad no
se dan cuenta de que en realidad ellos
también son una comunidad marginalizada
Lo siento que los asiáticos en especial
los que nacieron en Estados Unidos creen
que son blancos y no sienten ningún tipo
de empatía por el resto de las minorías
de la sociedad
todos sabemos que el colorismo existe he
tenido interacciones negativas con
asiáticos porque soy negro pero también
he tenido interacciones positivas creo
que estar de acuerdo sería generalizar a
toda una comunidad sé que sucede por
supuesto pero yo no he experimentado
racismo de parte de la comunidad
asiática estoy de acuerdo con el
concepto de colorismo porque parece que
mientras más oscuro eres más feo te
consideran es algo que pasa en cualquier
etnia y es terrible la forma de pensar
de Estados Unidos influye en Quién viene
a vivir aquí es imposible no notarla
cuando llegas a Estados Unidos y pasas
unos años aquí entiendes cómo funciona
todo y también te das cuenta que hay un
sistema donde a nosotros nos tratan
diferente luego de dejar el ejército
viví unos años en Malasia Singapur
Indonesia y Corea del Sur en estos
países me sentí más aceptado que en
Estados Unidos Me impactó que no me en
las tiendas de Corea del Sur por ejemplo
fue un shock que no me trataran o me
miraran de la forma en la que lo hacen
algunas personas en mi propio país
es sabido con personas de otras razas
[Música]
a lo largo de mi vida he probado casi
todos los Sabores
he salido con hombres asiáticos y
también latinos y es diferente nunca
encontrarás a alguien fuera de tu
comunidad y que entienda al 100% y que
comprenda tus dificultades tu familia y
por qué actúas de cierta manera cuando
salgo con estos hombres sé que la
dinámica será diferente creo que esa
mentalidad me ayuda a que la relación
funcione No creo que evitaría salir con
una persona Blanca pero siento que la
conexión no sería igual Aunque siempre y
cuando estén dispuestos a conversar
conmigo y entender el color de mi piel
Yo estaré de hablar con ellos sin
importar la raza que sean en mi caso
todo depende de mi comodidad de Y qué
tanto tengamos en común por eso siento
que las mujeres blancas estarían de
últimas en mi lista porque suelo tener
muchos puntos en común con ellas Aunque
no me negaría salir con una preferiría
salir con alguien con quien Ya sé que
hay cierta compatibilidad
no me molestaría pero en lo que respecta
al matrimonio quiero casarme con un
hombre negro claro nuestros ancestros
deben estar temblando en su estudio
mientras piensan que estás haciendo
hicimos tanto por ti y ahora quieres
estar con esa persona que no es negra
solo he salido con hombres negros pero
tal vez debería cambiar eso porque ellos
suelen preferir mujeres que no son
negros controlarlas
a que tienen facciones europeas y
cabello más suave quieren que su pareja
se parezca a Kim Kardashian quieren la
estética de una mujer negra pero
necesitan las facciones europeas Así que
tal vez debería salir con otros hombres
Pero como tú dices también quiero
casarme con un hombre negro y quiero
tener hijos negros Ese es mi sueño pero
con Esta generación de hombres negros no
creo que sea posible yo no podría tener
sexo con un hombre blanco tiene que ver
Breaking y toda la historia de nuestra
raza si todo está relacionado además
tener relaciones sexuales con una
persona negra suele ser un fetiche para
las personas de otras razas hasta en
relaciones heterosexuales no sexualizan
por tener un buen cuerpo por el color
hermoso y oscuro de nuestra piel o
porque tenemos esa herramienta que ellos
quieren si saben a qué me refieren
siempre están buscando algo de tu cuerpo
sé que puede llegar a ser Amor verdadero
es posible pero para mí salir con otras
razas es desagradable
me he sentido oprimido por mi propia
comunidad
[Música]
A veces me siento muy incómoda en
lugares repletos de personas negras si
no eres una mujer negra deseable si los
hombres no te encuentran atractiva ellos
suelen pasarte por alto debo partirme la
espalda para obtener las cosas que
quiero los hombres negros y en
específico cisgénero nos oprimen a todos
Yo quiero estar con un hombre negro pero
es complicado porque Debo llamar la
atención de mi opresor Soy homosexual y
también soy negro dentro de nuestra
comunidad siento que hay espacios
heterosexuales pueden ser protestas
clubes o fiestas donde los hombres
piensan él es negro pero es gay Así que
podemos meternos con él porque no
debería estar en nuestro espacio porque
hay reclamas un espacio como tuyo solo
por tu sexualidad y preferencias
sexuales en vez de compartirlos con
personas de tu misma raza estoy de
acuerdo si eres de la comunidad
lgbtq crean otra división las personas
no tienen problemas conmigo cuando pasó
como un hombre sin género negro pero sí
cuando descubren que soy transgénero por
mi experiencia personal siento que
algunas personas negras evitan que otras
tengan las mismas oportunidades es como
si quisieran evitar que otros tuviesen
éxito por eso los acosan y les dicen no
mereces estar en mi espacio Esta es mi
zona es el lugar donde yo trabajo
pareciera que quieren que las otras
personas negras fracasen he visto esa
dinámica muchas veces y a mí me ha
pasado
cuando vivía en Mississippi me rodeaba
de muchas personas negras y no me sentía
diferente Ahora que estoy en California
interactúa con más personas de otras
razas entiendo porque la gente considera
que hay colorismo y por qué a veces en
algunas situaciones siento que no valgo
lo mismo que estas otras personas sin
embargo no siento que usaría la palabra
oprimida para explicar cómo han sido mis
experiencias
alguna vez desearon no ser negros
[Música]
quiero que entiendan algo hoy en día Yo
me amo y amo ser una mujer negra pero
por mucho tiempo
conocidos y miembros de mi familia me
dijeron que era hermosa porque mi color
de piel no era tan oscuro como el de
otros eso causó que desde niña asociar
el hecho de ser negra con algo que
estaba muy mal también veía lo mal que
trataban a personas más oscuras que yo y
pensaba no quiero seguir siendo así
luego de muchos años
mucho amor propio y compasión conmigo
misma entendí que ser negro es lo mejor
del mundo
somos lo mejor
Esa es la verdad pero entiendo tu punto
eso tiene que ver con el colorismo se
hace mucho en nuestra comunidad y siento
que si todos decidiéramos aceptar
nuestro color nos sentiríamos mucho
mejor
cuando era joven me mudé a un vecindario
donde vivían muchos blancos e hispanos
nunca llegué a pensar Ojalá no fuese
negro pero sí veía a las personas y
decía Ojalá tuviese su cabello o me
pareciese más a ellos
mi color de piel y mi raza pero obtener
cabello 4c y nudillos y rodillas mucho
más oscuras no era algo fácil de llevar
cuando iba a la escuela fue una
pesadilla Y actualmente estoy
aprendiendo a aceptar todo mi cuerpo
pero es una batalla que luchó cada día
algunas veces he deseado no ser negra
estadounidense me gustaba la idea de ser
africana o brasilera porque siento que
los negros estadounidenses estamos
desconectados de nuestras raíces y
herencia africanas y eso me duele porque
no tenemos muchas cosas que sean
nuestras además de la lengua ebonic o el
inglés afroe estadounidense Aunque la
cultura negra estadounidense ha sentado
las pautas para la cultura pop moderna y
eso me hace sentir orgullosa
aún no criaría a mis hijos como mis
padres me criaron a mí
[Música]
si eres negro y no has tenido
experiencias de abuso sexual o algún
tipo de violencia en tu hogar tienes
mucha suerte porque eso nos ha pasado a
muchos como Yo viví eso durante mi
infancia jamás golpearía a mis hijos No
quiero sentir jamás que golpear a mi
hijo es la única forma de ganarme su
respeto quiero que hablemos de Salud
Mental y que se tomen en serio la Salud
Mental porque no es un tema del que se
habla en la comunidad negra
es cierto Me alegra que
había mencionado la Salud Mental porque
es un tema del que nunca podemos hablar
en nuestra comunidad si lo haces te
dicen cuál es tu problema Estás loco Te
voy a golpear no deberías actuar así Yo
te he dado todo no tienes porque estar
deprimidos no quiero pasarles esa idea a
mis hijos y mucho menos quiero que si
están deprimidos o se sienten abrumados
crean que no pueden venir a hablar
conmigo
mis padres no tuvieron la oportunidad de
hablar con sus padres porque son una
generación completamente diferente Ahora
entiendo que mi madre Me crió de la
forma en la que lo hizo porque Era lo
único que sabía pero el ciclo termina
conmigo
nuestros hijos también Pensarán no
criaré a mis hijos como mis padres lo
hicieron porque cada generación se
vuelve más sabia y tiene acceso a más
recursos que la anterior a mí me encanta
Resaltar las cosas buenas que hicieron
Mis padres ya identifiquéis todo lo malo
que hicieron así que puedo perdonarlos y
soltar es la única forma de aplicar Lo
bueno que he aprendido de ellos y
mezclarlo con mi visión
no puedo ser honesto sobre quién soy
como soy negro cuando estoy en un
espacio blanco siempre estoy pensando en
cómo me persiguen ser transgénero hace
que también piense si estoy caminando
bien si me dirigí bien a otras personas
y si me están juzgando nunca sé si otras
personas me están mirando porque no se
sienten cómodas es agotador tener que
pensar todo eso cuando estoy rodeado de
otras personas como estamos en la era de
cancelar todos Ahora las cosas son más
difíciles aunque quiero hacer honesto a
veces no puede serlo porque tienes miedo
a que te cancelen o a que te acocen en
algún lugar siento que en algunos
espacios no puedo expresar con toda
honestidad mi manera de ver el mundo por
miedo a cómo reaccionarán los demás
no es fácil para nadie despertar un día
y decidir ser tú mismo y empezar a estar
orgulloso de tu identidad sin importar
cual sea vivir ese proceso me hizo
entender que debo ser directo y siempre
debo ser yo y si no les gusta váyanse
Es agotador sentirse obligado a defender
quién eres todo el tiempo pero al final
del día duermo tranquila porque sé
que solo soy yo
[Música]